hi in this video I'll be talking about
archaea mainly the archaea bacteria now
this would be an introductory video so
first let me tell you our team actually
or archaea in terms of evolution are
quite different from Eukarya or bacteria
so in this video we'll be talking about
the similarities and the dissimilarities
with you bacteria so first let's talk
about how archaea bacteria is similar to
a you bacteria in several perspective
we'll be talking about their cellular
features their molecular features
metabolism their antibiotic sensitivity
evolutionary perspective habitat and
many others so let's begin so in terms
of size eubacteria and archaebacteria
both are pretty comparable and similar
now both eubacteria and archaebacteria
has plasmids so that's another
similarity between those and the in
terms of genome they are very similar
both eubacteria and archaebacteria has
70s ribosome in terms of protein
synthesis they are pretty similar and in
they all have oberon like Geno
organization both the cases they have
absence of histone like protein so these
are all similarities between them now in
terms of basic metabolic processes both
of them has a lot of similarity and you
must be amused to know that both are
Quebec bacteria and you bacteria can be
either gram positive or gram negative
and that totally depends upon their cell
wall composition now let's come to the
differences between archaea bacteria and
you bacteria the first difference we
should consider is at a cellular level
now in cellular level arca bacteria
differs from a new bacteria in terms of
cell wall composition cell membrane
composition
and tRNA structure etc etc so let's talk
about the cell wall composition first
whereas you bacterial cell wall is made
up of in acetyl glucosamine and
n-acetylmuramic acid our key bacterial
cell wall don't have an acetyl Meramec
acid instead it has n acetyl telus
Emerick acid so definitely the arca
bacterial cell wall is different in
terms of the composition and that gives
our key bacterial cell wall a different
property so architecture your cell wall
is resistant to lysozyme and many of
these beta lactam antibiotics such as
penicillin now in terms of cell membrane
algae bacteria contains phospholipids
but the phospholipids are different from
the UK you can do bacterias because the
you bacterias the phospholipid is kind
of linked to the glycerol moiety by
ester linkage whereas in case of our key
bacteria it has the ether linkage this
is the major difference in terms of cell
wall composition the cell cell membrane
composition but in case of and what is
it what is the implication of this
difference now this altered cell
membrane composition makes sure's that
our key bacteria is resistant to many of
the antibiotics that work upon cell
membrane now let's come to the molecular
features normally you bacterial
initiator trna fmet trna is absent in
case of the archaea bacteria
it has maturing linked trna instead of
formyl methionine not only that you
bacterial tRNA has pseudo you reading
but RT bacteria don't have pseudo you
reading so another important difference
between an architecture and new bacteria
is that the ribosome of you bacteria is
sensitive to chloramphenicol now
chloramphenicol act upon the peptidyl
transferase activity
which transfers the peptide bond born
from one amino acid to another an amino
acid and thereby allowing the peptide
chain to grow hello Doron pinnacle
prevent this step now our key bacterial
cell wall is our key bacterial ribosome
is actually resistant to chloramphenicol
activity also the RNA polymerase of you
bacteria is sensitive to rifampicin
but our key bacterial RNA polymerase is
insensitive or protective against
rifampicin
treatment in terms of metabolism archaea
bacteria shows mithun biosynthesis
pathway and this maternal genetic
pathway is presenting many classes of
archaebacteria they are known as
maternal genes and about which I'll be
talking in a separate video now in terms
of habitat the are key bacteria are
present in extreme conditions where
other life-forms cannot survive for
example you would find maternal genes in
marshy swamps and other environments and
the maternal genes are the largest group
in our key bacteria which I would be
talking later also you would find
thermal fields and the name suggests
they are present in extreme hot
environments like hot springs or deep
sea hydrothermal vents where temperature
can rise as far as 150 degree centigrade
now Paulo files are another group of
archaea bacteria and hallow files are
present in extreme salty environment and
their biggest family is shallow
bacterium selenium and I'll be talking
about them in a different video but
these the speciality of these Halla
bacterium are take and carry out
photosynthesis without a chlorophyll and
they can use bacteria rhodopsin to do
the photosynthesis part so this video
was overview of the features of our key
bacteria and how they are similar or
different from you bacteria I hope you
understand this introductory video in my
next video I'll be talking about a lot
more details about these subclasses of
our key bacteria so if you enjoyed my
video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to like share and subscribe
thank you